[Music]
starring in our Saturday sessions this
morning Lucy Degas the Virginia native
cut our first album is a project in
music school the album was a hit with
critics and got her signed to a record
deal in a profile last month the New
York Times called Dacus a timeless model
a guitar based album oriented songwriter
with a big unadulterated voice and
tattoo above lyrics just last week she
released historian her much anticipated
follow-up and now to perform her new
single addictions here is Lucy Degas
freeze-frame
[Music]
[Music]
this time
[Music]
to be
[Music]
remember me dive on July play in there
back on the road
Shiela play
[Music]
he's so hard to have you back my son
[Music]
[Music]
hi
[Music]
it's calling cuz I'm used to it new
pickup cuz you're not quitter
you've got addictions - it's true
got addictions too
[Music]
[Music]
she's calling cuz on these two in your
pickup cuz you're not a quitter
you've got addictions - it's true
[Music]
addictions
[Music]
you've got a dick
[Music]
addictions - no go away we'll be right
back with more music from Lucy Dacus
you're watching CBS this morning
Saturday Saturday sessions are sponsored
by Blue Buffalo you love your pets like
family so feed them like family with
blue